wir versuchen das jetzt erstmal mit dem
kollegen fabian matzerath er kann sich
von oben einen überblick verschaffen
über die demonstrationen
es steht an der friedrichstraße wir
sehen hier die bilder live gerade fahren
ich hoffe dass sie schaltet zu dir steht
und dass du uns einen eindruck
vermitteln kann wie die situation im
moment von oben mit blick auf die
demonstration aussieht hallo hallo
ja ich bin hier wirklich straße ecke
torstraße
dort ist er anfang des
demonstrationszuges der aber nicht
losgelaufen lassen wird weil die
friedrichstraße total voll ist jene
maßnahmen abstände werden nicht
eingehalten
die leute tragen einen mund nasen schutz
und die polizei lässt sie nicht los
gehen hat jetzt nicht nur spaß
friedrichstraße polizei fahrzeuge
blockiert
haben wir haben es vorhin in den bildern
gesehen dort wirkte die stimmung
aufgeheizt polizisten wurden
angeschrieben
wie kannst du mit diesem überlegt die
nur jetzt hast die stimmung im moment
wahrnehmen
die stimmung ist sehr gut auch
geschrieben wieder spannend widerstand
widerstand lasst uns durch lasst uns
gerücht lasst uns durch aber es passiert
doch nichts
die polizei ist auf matschiner hat auch
direkt auf anderen abschnitten und jetzt
kommen weitere leute aus den
seitenstraßen von links und von rechts
und skandieren
fabian matzerath vielen herzlichen dank
für diesen überblick zunächst